what is going on everybody and welcome
to part three of the reinforcement
learning with the biddle robot dog and
nvidia's isaac sim
a lot has happened since the last video
each step a little baby step sometimes
backwards but overall i'm getting much
closer to my end goal and i'm learning a
ton on the way
the very first thing i did since part
two was try adding a camera to the
biddle
my thinking here was that a camera would
be capable of informing the biddle of at
minimum the horizon but also later even
more information such as objects that
the biddle would need to navigate around
and so on the real biddle also has a
front camera option so this seemed like
a really good next step so i learned how
to attach the camera in the isaac sim
and then all that was left was well how
to access the camera and actually get
the data but we have the camera next for
anybody who is following along i don't
believe i ever explained how to change
the color the official way in the
documentation just doesn't actually seem
to work for me so the way that i've been
doing it is under that looks section of
the biddle uh dog in the sim you can
change the material color manually there
the main code to get the data from the
camera is here and after running into a
bunch of errors and using opencv instead
of matplotlib to show it here's an
example of the output so now that i've
got the camera finally working the first
thing i want to do is save a bunch of
these frames so that i can use them to
train an auto encoder on the imagery the
idea here is once i have an auto encoder
trained i can use the encoder part to
encode the imagery from the camera down
to something like four flat features for
example if you're not familiar with auto
encoders i did a video tutorial on them
and i'll put a link to that in the
description so now that i've got the
data i whip up an auto encoder again i'm
just going to zoom through this the auto
encoder and the concept of an auto
encoder is super basic the idea here is
that we're just going to have some
unconvolutional layers then flattened
down to a fully connected chokepoint
that is as small as i can get to start i
literally just copy and pasted the code
from the autoencoders tutorial on
pythonprogramming.net
after copying and pasting i just spent
some time changing some of the variables
hitting some errors fixing those errors
and i was on my way trading the auto
encoder once the auto encoder was
trained i wanted to see both the fully
encoded features of course and then also
the result of decoding back to get an
idea for any information loss that's
going on and also just to see how small
of a choke point can we get away with so
here are some examples essentially there
are three photos this is a 25 feature
choke point for the image so the image
is input into the auto encoder and then
it's encoded down to in this case 25
values the first photo that you see is
the original the second photo is a
visualization of the 25 values just in a
5x5 grid format and the third photo on
the bottom is decoded as the original
it's just basically the original image
decoded back so as you can see there's
definitely some noise some information
loss but that's perfectly fine all i
think i need to capture in these
features right now is the horizon and i
think we've done that here's another
example
i then try to go from 25 features down
to nine retraining the auto encoder and
again i check some samples and that also
seems fine and i even did a four feature
and again that seems totally fine for my
needs
to be honest it might even be possible
that this can be encoded into a single
feature but right now i want to see does
this work in the bot in the sim
unfortunately it's at this point where i
learn how much this camera sensor seems
to slow everything down what you see
here is me printing out the frame number
per frame in the sim and this is real
time
it's very slow
it's too slow
it looks like about seven steps per
second we can expect to do millions of
steps per model test and a sufficiently
trained model to be about 50 million
steps just to guess at seven steps per
second that puts us to 7.14 million
seconds that's 119 000 minutes 1984
hours and 82 days
that's a few days too many in my opinion
if i ever get to training in real life
that is probably something i'll be
looking at in terms of time to train but
the point of the sim is to speed up the
r d the slow down here appears to all
boil down to line 40 which is where
we're actually grabbing the camera
sensor's values
i don't know any way around this this
has to be done in the loop every step
there's got to be a better way i'm sure
there is i just don't know it in my hunt
to speed up the camera i stumbled upon
an imu sensor example here you can see
me poking this little ant thing and the
sensor values are updating in the imu
sensor example window if you don't know
imu stands for inertial measurement unit
and it's used to measure forces on in
axes so also the the real bitter robot
has one
it looked to me like the imu response
right here was extremely fast and
cherry on top there was sample code to
go with it
in my opinion the imu readings are
probably even better than the auto
encoded video at least for now there are
other things that we can get from video
that we can't get from an imu sensor but
for now this is pretty good
i'd call this lemonade out of lemons
using the imu demo script i start to
port over everything to my biddle
attaching the imu itself adding in the
code that will let us probe the imu data
and then printing it out to see if it
actually worked running everything looks
like it indeed actually worked and if i
move one of the legs we can see the imu
data is indeed updating and we can see
it's happening very fast
around the time that i'm rnd the camera
sensor a new version of isaac sim comes
out with various major changes and i
accidentally delete the entire project
directory when uninstalling the older
sim version so
i wind up rewriting the whole agent and
sim code
not the worst thing ever though i kind
of already wanted to rewrite it just to
clean it up essentially anyways so cool
after doing all of that i finally have
my first working observations and
actions environment along with those imu
readings for the observations and we're
ready to learn some stuff
one of the other additions that i wanted
to make was something to better punish
for this like wiggling jitteriness
various commenters brought up things
like mimicking lactic acid and such i
thought about measuring how wiggly a
line was and embarked down a journey of
measuring the smoothness of a line
but eventually i went with just simply
punishing for every direction change
if you jitter a lot the punishment is
very high and if you take strides the
punishment is very low i then work to
apply this but not only does this take a
while i'm also simultaneously trying to
get things like continuous ppo to work
as well as soft after critic and even
discrete delta ppo as one of the viewers
suggested i try but every move i make
takes a very long time to apply now and
weaving each individual algorithm into
my current environment is very
messy
it would help to convert my environment
to a full-on gym inheriting environment
and if i'm doing that i might as well
start using stable bass lines 3 which
will make iteration much faster
stable baselines 3 is for reinforcement
learning in python like sk learn is for
general machine learning the idea is to
make reinforcement learning very modular
and easy to apply various reinforcement
learning algorithms to your problem to
make actual use of stable baselines 3
you need to convert your environment to
an actual gym environment with at
minimum an init step and reset method
for something like the simulator here
that closes very messy
if you just break it you might also want
to have a close method that cleanly
closes the environment once you've
converted your environment while stable
baselines 3 does have a quick sort of
check end method i find this doesn't
really fully inform you if things are
going to work right so i went ahead and
just made a double check and to make
sure things are stepping and resetting
and cycling episodes as we hope and
finally i get to the point where it
works and now i'm ready to play with
some new algorithms and stable baselines
3 in general one of the other early
initial things i added in is frame
stacking which is where rather than
having a single observation per step we
have a stack of historical observations
and the current observation so there's a
slight history of what's been going on
after this i start training and
comparing models across various
algorithms like td 3 ppo and sac i also
begin testing different hertz
refresh rates essentially how many steps
per second
does the biddle do things i originally
was doing 60 since that's the
simulator's default but then i found 30
to be a bit better i also tinker a bit
with forcefully smoothing moves various
frame stack sizes obviously other hurts
rates and much more and then this is
also where i began poking into discrete
delta ppo
since so far this seems to be my best
performer let's cover the concept of
discrete delta with classifiers like
native ppo robotics with motors and
servos and such is generally seen as a
continuous control type of problem it's
not a question of classification like go
left or go right
you might have a higher level control
algorithm that does something like that
but when you're trying to control servos
it's a question of what position do we
want to set the motor to this is a
continuous type problem and these are
much more challenging to solve with
gradient descent just in general if you
can pick any number between negative 1
and positive 1 there are theoretically
infinite choices of course with many
electronic components they are mapped to
values like 0 up to
32768 or something like that so this is
theoretically actually discrete but
these are way too many discrete values
for an actual classifier and this is why
they're considered continuous problems
instead to understand why this isn't
treated as a discrete problem even
though it theoretically is
discrete
you would want to imagine having
training data that shows based on some
input you want to set the servo to let's
say 10 000 but the algo picks 1001 well
1001 would be considered wrong and this
is why we want to treat it more like a
regression style problem rather than a
classification problem
but again this is very costly because
treating something this way takes much
longer to solve because of gradient
descent and just the nature of having
near infinite possibilities
so the concept of discrete delta aims to
solve this
consider having three discrete deltas
negative 0.1 0 and 0.1
think of these like relative values from
the current position
whichever of the three classifications
of discrete values that the algorithm
chooses is simply added to whatever your
current position is so no longer are
there infinite possibilities or even 32
000 possibilities there's really just
three so imagine your current position
is 0.62 and the algorithm picks 0.1 you
add 0.1 to 0.62 and you get your new
desired motor position of 0.72 if we're
acting at 30 hertz for example this
means we can go fully in both directions
three whole times a second which for our
little biddle is way more than enough
but we might also want some more fine
motor control than that that might even
be too fast so something like seven bins
might work and here are just some two
examples of some bins or classifications
that i have personally tried on this
problem with these we have some fairly
large acting possibilities we've got
some medium and some fine motor control
right so we have everything from very
quick rapid movements to very subtle
ones and instead of having nearly
infinite or even 32 000 possibilities we
have seven and this is much easier for
an algorithm to actually learn as i get
into some of the results i couldn't
possibly show every single version and
every single test that i ran it was
easily in the hundreds but i can at
least give some highlights so first some
of the things that i tried i tried
various hurts so 120 60 50 30 20 and 10.
i tried td3 sac ppo discrete delta and
continuous i tried because i ended up
mostly going with discrete delta ppo i
tried various deltas as well as numbers
of deltas so
different delta numbers but then also
like maybe only three or five or seven
or nine and so on and then also various
movement punishments more on that in a
little bit and then also frame stacks so
again the historical observations coming
through
for the current observation i tried 3 7
20 and 60 for example
so now for what actually worked the best
performing algorithm by far is discrete
delta ppo uh it is possible though that
you know because it's discrete delta
it's going to learn
faster than something like soft actor
critic or td 3 for example so or
continuous ppo so it's possible i just
simply wasn't patient enough and
more more research is going to be needed
there uh the deltas that i went with uh
were the following negative 0.3 negative
0.1 negative 0.03 and so on back to the
positives
again i tried many different deltas many
different numbers of delta so as you can
see here this was seven deltas that i
ended up going with
the hertz was 20. i found the lower
hertz tended to to do better but 20 and
10 were pretty equal in performance and
i felt like 20 actions per second was
better than 10 most likely so that's
what i went with and honestly i have no
idea what what's the actual realistic
hurts that i could achieve on the biddle
uh like physically i don't i don't
actually know next we had movement
punishments uh the main punishment here
being left to right movement right the
what i'm trying to do is is develop a
straight walking gait so any movement
left to right is a direct punishment and
then i did other various punishments
like punishing for wiggles and punishing
for just trying to get the gate to be
more realistic so many people suggested
before doing things like simulating like
lactic acid and stuff like that and i
did find that of all my crazy ideas the
best idea that performed the best was
quite literally just a punishment every
time the servo direction changed so so
the calculation for that is just like 5
is this 5a basically it's every single
movement that was made divided by um the
move punish div and then i just square
this so the move punish div is 80 and
then all movements is actually every
servo direction change from the last 20
steps again this was just yet another
hyper parameter that i tested but 20
steps is one second at 20 hertz so every
single direction change of a servo is a
punishment for the last second
essentially and again i tried all kinds
of different ideas but this seems to be
the one that worked out best so getting
into some of the results now this is a
seven frame stack discrete delta ppo or
ddpo example no movement punishment and
it's a good example of what can happen
if you don't punish jittery movement
along with an example of how these
reinforcement learning algorithms can
find themselves in a sort of local
optimum for rewards
that it's going to be nearly impossible
for that model to ever break away from
ever again into the future
it also looks like it could be a slight
abuse of physics in this case now here
is a more appropriate
gate and walker this is a seven stack
ddppo with jitter punishment and this is
about 10 million steps into training and
just to be clear
the console that you see there the
leftmost number is the total reward and
then the other number is that the reward
for that very specific step
so this isn't the straightest of walkers
but there is a clear gate here it's the
first of the models to really give me
any hope that this this could ever
uh work
and also check out this move about two
million more steps into training that
same model it's beginning to look pretty
good but the upper legs don't really
seem to want to move very much but
honestly models like this are
super rare to get most of the time what
i'm seeing is more like
a true winners like this and he's not
done yet
there we go
as cool as a model that does that uh to
travel might be i'm really after a
regular walking gate
and then there's models like this guy
all i can say here is that reinforcement
learning algorithms have no vanity they
do not care how silly they look
and you might be wondering how this
model ever learned to do this over
something else
and my suspicion is this is probably to
blame
i don't know what's going on there but
again abuse of physics so this is the
model where i finally begin to settle on
most parameters i'm all in on discrete
delta ppo
uh and those parameters i settled on are
the ones that i showed earlier like 20
hertz 80 punish div seven frame stack
uh the deltas that i showed earlier and
so on i like this one a lot it looks
like a realistic gate
uh there's obviously tons of room for
improvement but this shows a lot of
promise and this is about five million
steps
into training
unfortunately this model evolves into
this model about 11 11 million steps in
while the average reward here is better
i'm
not really a big fan it clearly wants to
keep a very low center of gravity
and you can also see it's doing this
sort of like move stop move stop move
stop and it's subtle here
but about 20 million steps in here's our
guy
it's not ideal it's a very reliable and
stable gate but
i'm just not a fan
yeah you can even see that when this
model does trip itself up it is capable
of recovering and continuing on its way
which again is
is cool but i'm just not the biggest fan
of this gate
for the final biddle model for this
video i went ahead and added a
punishment for the z axes
bounce that's been going on and this is
done in the form of a standard deviation
specifically i'm just simply calculating
numpy standard deviation of the z
history uh the reward is then just a
minus equals of the standard deviation
and then i'm dividing again by a
standard
deviation division
similar to the other divisions that i've
done like with movements and stuff
so the standard deviation is applied to
a history of 10.
i actually have not tinkered much with
making that 20 or you know any other
number so 10 is just the one that i went
with i i basically just ran it in the
simulator looked at some of the outputs
and tweaked that until it was a number
that i felt like yeah that's how much i
want to punish it so
probably more r d could be could be done
there
and
honestly this one reminds me of some of
the earlier models before they became
hoppers it's definitely more of a walker
fairly stable good reliable rewards
i think the biggest thing that i notice
now is that body roll
i am tempted to also punish for the role
as well we can access that with the imu
but i'm
i'm just kind of weary about how much
restriction and i do kind of wonder if
we just let these models go for a few
more tens of millions of steps if things
would just smooth out on their own
because it's more efficient
this model is 20 million steps in so far
and the hoppy model
i let continued training and is
currently 65 million steps in still
hopping around so i think to some extent
a natural gait would be naturally found
but it's also true that gates in real
life are indeed determined by limiting
factors like minimizing energy costs and
joint wear and tear and then also just
body stability is definitely a thing it
makes sense so that the animal's head
and brain isn't just bouncing around and
so vision is stable so it's tough for me
to come up with final decisions about a
good balance for for rewards and
restrictions and stuff and every time
you introduce some new punishment you
run the risk of adverse impacts that you
just did not foresee or intend so
anyways definitely still much more trial
and error to
get through i'm definitely still
learning a ton of new information and
new things i also appreciate all the
comments lots of great suggestions and
also just discreet delta ppo is
something that came from a comment i
don't think i would have stumbled on
that on my own so
yeah thanks to everyone for your input
so that's all for now if you'd like to
learn more about neural networks and how
they work there's a book maybe you've
heard of called neural networks from
scratch by myself and daniel kukewa you
can learn more about that at nnfs.io
otherwise i will see you all in another
video
you